un petit break petit bref petit bras
qu'est ce cas
brest merde on arrive on revient à je
vais rester là comme ça ouais signal
bonjour madame vous comme un indien
savamment soutien auquel vas-y des
breaks débreaks et on a ri est par
contre on arrive à les weppes empédocle
quoi pour qui la déchire
par contre sur ram 10 min couple est en
place et maintenant
voici à l'école j
à
et qu'elle faisait ça fait une paye dans
cette affaire trois quatre ans annonce a
fait de pilates heures c'est sa maison
montparnasse avait dit que le public dit
s'il avait la pêche prochain quoi quoi
là on est dans le calcul plus précis ce
côté les vrais magistrats
que ça va
je vais nombre des vosges à l'été
au delà des pas de danse côté et on s'en
fout on allait bel
à 28 ans elle était là dans cinq ans
ce cas nous y sont en bonne santé
long de son poteau
bien aidé au soir maison soir bonsoir
messieurs bonsoir monsieur ramzy après
le triomphe de la tour montparnasse
infernale 2 millions d'entrées vous
revenez eric et ramzy dans double zéro
bonsoir
le deuxième qui tenait deux rôles
principaux
merci beaucoup voilà avec céline
agressif mais dont les noms n'ont pu
voir des sections mais voilà après bien
ça fait du bien ça s'est très bien passé
servier c'était grave vraiment le cas
double zéro c'est bonsoir oui bonsoir
merci quand allez-vous ce temps bree ça
va être à nous avons bientôt on nous
invite après la vache
ouais classe c'est pas mal à libérer
terry lavage non oui je pense que là bas
je vais monde croyait aller bien moche
et ça s'appelle daniel mouchet
et éric et lavage ouais alors ramzy
alors vérité la main j'avais fait la
malle or not to be tant que joueuse
remake on fait la promo y apprend métro
qu'il opère la prison les tenait alors
double zéro produit par thomas langmann
réalisé par gérard pirès avec eric judor
soir bonsoir
ramzy bedia chanter et jouer harbert
françois berléand
mais non c'est pas non mais c'est pas
françois berléand notion est cru d'abord
je voudrais qu'on a fait signer aussi
c'est vraiment mais est ce que j'ai vu
le pire semblait pas trop à françois
berléand son château si louis et ya
rossy de palma et lionel abelanski alors
est et puis à plus fort que tout ne l'a
pas non lic style awards jolis seins à
lérida des rides fera la tuerie qu'elle
est belle à la mesure a quasiment de
métal et non c'est la plus grande
chinoise des chine
ah ouais j'avais chinoise et des fois
les immenses voiles a sorti le 16 juin
bonsoir je crois que vous avez tout dit
le pitch de the pitt ce nom peu le
raconte en fait la france livre un
missile zator l'insuffisance ça fait
longtemps ça fait une paye je fais plus
du tout quoi pardon je te fais et
j'avais bien commencé non franchement
riches n'ont en effet le site est super
c'est moi donc un missile est livrée par
les français aux russes ce missile se
fait subtiliser là-dessus la france
envoie des espions français donc de la
dgse pour enquêter pour savoir qui a
fait le coup je le connais depuis des
mois fais moi et ils on voit deux appât
pour attirer les deux chèvres de chèvre
pour attirer l'ennemi pendant que les
deux super espion font leurs missions et
les deux a pas on leur fait croire
qu'ils sont géniaux et chez nous je
pense vraiment qu'on et géniaux ouais en
plus à ces géniaux puisqu'à la sortie
c'est quand même vous qui gagnez bien
sûr a donc on raconte la fin
non mais on a sauvé la tour montparnasse
n'a sauvé le 14e arrondissement de paris
à trois ans on se dit maintenant sauver
le monde
voilà le monde est il à dire pour sauver
le monde vous affrontez un méchant qui
s'appelle le mal qui est interprété par
edouard baer est revoilà fans
entouré d'une armée de top model juste
vous allez bientôt les deux là on avait
regardé la caméra wi a salué le rouge
qui s'allume comme ça et j'avais dit
attention à 3 0 et auxerre 1 2 3 enfin
tu fais le staff est un bouffon l'aurait
dit mike faire sinon extrait partie
ratage connaisseurs et ben vas-y c'est
pas d'excès sylvie fait il le lance
quand il veut mais non il ne lancera pas
je suis à manier le martyr hamza on est
vraiment à sa botte
il faut dire on acquiert durs
magnétiques quoi exactement
ils ont dit non ouais ça mattern serge
la grande famille tous les airs de la
réalisation dit magnéto serge du mag
nette hausse et hakim est aussi aumônier
de ma cops et magnétoscopes cherche
manière sèche magnétoscope cherche